first off best all right I'm saying
that's how we're running [__] things
here [__] festos comes out festive
little festive that's your name little
festivals festivals pesto's I suppose
best those Dominus does
never a dull [__] moment with
uncle Joey Diaz I'm lucky you're [__]
we into we interrupted your regularly
scheduled program to bring you this bad
[__] and there's a little Jewish
boom bar Lisa at it's one of those
nights [__] you want it you got
it
we got Russian refund we got [__]
mushrooms from Kentucky
we got mushrooms from Alabama plus plus
look at this [__] tonight we're gonna
back the star shipment comes in tomorrow
200 milligrams we'll be prepared for
Boston
we got a mule headed to Boston as we
speak we got a mule headed to Foxwoods
as we speak and that's it and that's
that you understand me so get ready to
run he was sitting there going when is
my ship gonna come in when is my ship
gonna come in well guess what
[__] it's the Queen Mary in full
[__] effect we got Felipe's bars
around the way but until then we're
gonna have our own little [__] party
we write in our own movies we make our
own books on the turntable the b-52s
rock lobster album 1980 one of the
greatest albums of our [__] generation
are you [__] kidding me Lana this
thing smells we tell them all this weed
smells you understand me
and it's dry it's brittle I had in the
car all day yesterday
when I open up the door he was waiting
for me an attention
[Music]
we got time to [__] around tonight if
you're in the 18 hang up now if you're
not getting ready to get the party
started
go steal grandma's volumes and a foot
powder it's over [__]
we're gonna start the night off with a
little edible Eddy battle on a French
dog these [__] if you get him
get him he can all 200 milligrams it's
pure 200 milligrams of [__] debt you
understand me
debt last night I was watching our da
[__] the Ferguson I couldn't even see
it
that was a double vit was last time you
got double vision from THC they come
like a little piece of butter and four
pieces we'd all fall we don't have time
to [__] around you want to eat two of
them go hang out with somebody else here
don't worry about where I get the
[__] French ones all right we always
get the fresh [__] we got the juice when
you got the juice you walked in these
places they know they can't [__] with
uncle Joey they can't give you this [__]
they give the regular Gentiles the
movies and your [__] eyeballs in your
head look at this leaf sit neck um I
don't get the freshman's guys you go
back there negotiate they know you're
Jewish they give you five hours off but
they give you the old ones look at this
will go crazy tonight here don't go
nowhere
look at this stacked on like [__]
chips
we don't [__] around on the church I
don't know what you the church is a
state of mind you understand me the
state of mine is dirt anyway we got
mushrooms we got everything tonight you
understand it's that type of night so if
you had plans to be a Christian go [__]
yourself you're not gonna come true here
for you this is deep deep night tonight
here on the church so I don't know what
your plans are tomorrow
call your boss right now telling me that
[__] vertigo it works for me
you take this right here game from
Planet oh yeah you take this right here
sekai no fingernails look at this
ba-ba-ba-boom look at that like a
[__] like jelly Inigo it tastes like
[__] oil it would change your [__]
car and the oil goes in your mouth
that's what it tastes like
yup [__] I'm looking but you
don't know what I'm as you need the oil
that's the lubricates the joint somewhat
now to make you see into the future two
down four down one to go you understand
me look like this terrific see you
mother Beach oh [__] look at least say I
get all sour puss
[Music]
look he is puking already three days
with the girlfriend I mean stop eating
stars you only need 200 milligrams of
mama I know this [__] guy better
heroes or something nothing he went and
got stars like a half a [__] I said get
these [__] killers he gets done
[Music]
[Laughter]
three down listen you want to hang out
with your buddies and some [__]
coffee shop make believe you're a
beatnik be right ahead
we don't make believe nothing here we
take it to the next [__] level with
you or without you
so you tell me what you want to do how
you don't Lee all right you over there
puke and your eyeballs are trying to
rent you ain't seen nothing yet
[Music]
these little flash dose that's a little
fast dose it's my dog is [__] he dressed
up profess to follow me he's fast the
first days that fester he's fresh dose
that's a new breed of first listen yeah
that's like fastest nephew and [__] oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[__] what have you done
I didn't do nothing either don't feel
bad down the whole [__] thing we
found a hatch let's do this [__] enough
with the drama we got bong hits coming
you gotta be prepared for life here the
Marines are coming we got mushrooms
you're over there [__] around that's
a boy will you trouble for this ain't
Jesus this is [__] edible THC
[__] let's do this
look look yeah [__] skin [__] up
people you know everybody thinks that
Friday yeah sadly that's Amateur Night
the Lord's Day is when you want to see
the W actually double let you see it
Friday and Saturday is the Sun they can
get but in simplest [__]
[Music]
oh [__] it's time for Lee's first pocket
[__] around all weekend give mom a
hug she [__] tastes like [__] motor
oil and [__]
Tanya they put motor on this [__]
edible I don't mind I don't give a [__]
at this point do you believe Katrina
shrimp for last two [__] years we
think Bartha we think that [__]
Hillary cells you and [__] Hillary's
been buying Katrina fresh for years
remember when you were my man my hand
there we go little Baca Felicia do you
remember
[Music]
oh my god we ain't [__] around so I'm
telling you this reef oh yeah this is
this is guys I don't even break it don't
even come with a [__] label what is
that tight the label was like the devil
getting hit in the head with a bat
that's when you know the weight is good
when I'm enjoying are we with the devil
get hit with a bat it's it's tremendous
you ready for Bhagat number still we
gotta speed up the process to put some
green stuff in here so it's black don't
call him fast ghost why don't you dance
with me
I'm not Nolan burger
[Music]
Festo's is going down best those pesto's
oh gee that's the name of this week oh
gee [__] that's this mess around
round everybody goes the party oh [__]
they dance this mess around here we go
[__]
[Music]
here we go
Airbnb for one hit me hit me hit me hit
me hit me shake did you say bonk it yes
you did you bad [__] what makes
you feel better
[Music]
come on you say Joey what timing
I got open the door to decompress this
[__] plate look at leech
these little beady eyes he's back to the
funk of Israel somewhere listen to
Godfather music and [__]
[Music]
oh [__] Wayne [__] around no more
this from my girl Nicole thank you they
call you bad [__] uncle Joey
loves you look at that right in the
office we don't [__] around understand
me
[Music]
that's beautiful Nicole right there with
my boyfriend and [__] nice people see
god Bless America god bless you
[__] but now it's it's the
moment you've been waiting for
oh [__] we'll combine these
[__] I'm saying do not stop
until my ball blows up here here we go a
little rock lobster for you [__]
we got a great week coming up we got
another podcast Tuesday we are Boston
Friday for the Wahlberg it's sold out
but we're taking a party right to
Connecticut to the Fox will Country Club
the show starts at 7:30
don't be something by 9:30 10:00 and
we'll catch the end of McGregor Alvarez
who's better than you [__] huh
no body
lobster should we do another [__] with
the [__] time waits for nobody
understand when in doubt it's time for
Jerry's kids little bargain never kill
nobody understand
oh [__] little rock lobster we think you
do you think I'm gonna show up with some
flock in unum talking about some [__] I
don't give a [__] about real-life [__]
no I show up slinging dick giving our
bubblegum bong hits commentary and most
importantly nothing but love for you
[__] you know why does not you
[__] I got nothing
so if I'm gonna get down I get down with
you [__] we get down to the
ground you follow me why not you sit
down watch watch 60 minutes what are you
talking about the election the [__]
Zika virus [__] that makes me [__]
depressed
understand I wanna be a happy mother
[__] you follow me oh [__]
just when you thought it was safe
[__] rock lobster we were at a
party who the air hose Oh trouble
trouble and we got it's vegan night
tonight we got a giant clam
oh [__] just when you thought it was
safe in the house both my brother's yeah
man by the French Philippe [__]
Silent Bob the manager all [__] looking
good it's an island what's up fool
what's the website what's up fool
all right so Lee pace worldcom is what
I'm talking about
listen let me tell you something we're
going deep tonight 1980 lead you want
you ready for your mushroom with a name
this one I smelt it
it looks like my fungi toenail oh [__] I
already ate two of these [__]
and we often run jack
you wanna mushroom rougaille though
something insane will something at the
blog going here ego for the scent a foxy
I'm saying I'm doing for yourself do it
for vicente fox this [__] there you go
looking over there
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh [__] we go listen to me I don't give
a [__] if you play the violin
if you know anything about the guitar
catch this [__] God rest his
soul he's in heaven with a syringe in
his arm but that's his [__] business
this guy the first two albums it was too
much it was true [__] much listen to
my plywood Idaho the beginning of my
primal animal it's it's too much even
randy rhoads ago what the [__] going
on it oh [__] oh [__] oh lobster oh [__]
here we go [__]
[Music]
'we moots drinks falling down reefer or
Bendel in your pocket and these
[__] up on stage New Year's Eve
1914 ad ferny basta pseudo dropping
classes are you [__] crazy
let's do this [__] holy [__] are you
[__] kidding me
or what people I don't know what the
[__] you were thinking on the Lord's Day
well it's Sunday night the lead plays
here the managers here
Rodrigo's here Lisa at still gagging on
muscles I can't pull the [__] some fun
listen is this how you eat a mushroom
like a [__] rat tail you looked at
[__] in the eye and you will you
can suck my dick that's how you eat a
muscle it's all the state of mental bong
it dog oh [__] feeling good looking good
billy-ray get your [__] together get
that bomb over there son let's do this
[__]
this ain't no [__] average party with
people are talking about politics you
can suck my dick
it's up young dick [__] trump ain't
gonna save you and Hillary ain't gonna
save you he knows gonna save you you and
[__] Jesus Christ that's it
here you go Tarzan going that book for
Jesus Christ on Tuesday watch them all
looky who'd you vote for
Jesus [__]
[Music]
if you're an SPD tomorrow but the
Peconic plugger tomorrow I don't need
you here tonight
we got member good spirits here today
for one more [__] song for you and
that's it
you [__] around for that people I
told you rate your grandmother's [__]
medicine I don't give a [__] arthritic
or whatever the [__] it is it's gonna
work with a couple cocktail and if
they're expired that's even better
I've eaten expired pills for years I'm
[__] fine I got a I'm gonna take you
[__] in a deep world with
oh [__] little rats do it old-school
I'm gonna play for this for you
[__] you gotta lose your mind
this [__]
who said bonded did you say found you I
said bonded concept
I love you honey where's that liner here
we go 4d go straight out the box this is
old-school rocks do it
listen to this [__] old-school the
Indians are coming those are smoke
signals there's Indians waking up right
now in New Jersey gone what the [__] was
that
[Music]
oh yeah I don't you put your slippers or
[__] Leptis it's over get in the back
don't do u-turns go through about 19
youth is it we gotta finish these
mushrooms yeah they have an exploration
yes they do
[Music]
when you thank you but there's no
substitute for love oh [__] what's up
dog
Uncle Joe again with his nephew Felipe
it's only understand I don't know what
you were gonna do tonight what you were
thinking but you made the right choice
[Music]
oh this beautiful cap it looks and
smells like my fungi don't we [__]
around we eat that thing like a [__]
soldier a debt like this
[Music]
it would stop and suck that [__] watch
your generation let's do this
[__] you've been home all weekend
you thought Joey was dead [__] my mother
grave like police wouldn't hang up I
maybe what I think acute but there's no
substitute for love create enough ass
[__] the blood
boogie I will be back packs up to 10
minutes where we going
youtube.com but it's /c / Joey Diaz
YouTube back club tri-c / Joey Diaz
I'll see you [__] in 10 minutes
Stabler
[Music]